[Music]
biological databases have been
invaluable for managing these data
and for making them accessible depending
on the data that they contain
the databases fulfill different
functions
however one of the major problem is that
each of these database resources
contains a different subset of
biological knowledge
although each database can answer
questions in its domain
it cannot help with questions that span
domain boundaries
for example the flybase database does
not know about orthology relationships
the institute for genomic research tiger
database can help with orthology
but not with map position and the ucsc
database knows nothing about the fly
as this example shows researchers must
become adept at database surfing to
answer many reasonable questions
imagine life would be much simpler if
there was a single biological database
but this would be a poor solution the
diverse databases reflect the expertise
and interests of the groups that
maintain them
a single database would reflect a series
of compromises that would ultimately
impoverish the information resources
that are available to the scientific
community
a better solution would be to maintain
the scientific and political
independence of the databases
but allow the information that they
contain to be easily integrated to
enable cross database queries
there are many integration challenges
one of the most difficult is the one
that might seem the most minor
how do you assign and maintain the
correct names of biological objects
across
databases for example consider the dna
damage checkpoint pathway gene that is
named rad 24
in saccharomyces cerevisiae or budding
yeast
saccharomyces palmer fission yeast also
has a gene named rad 24
that is involved in the checkpoint
pathway but
it is not the orthologue of the
saccharomyces cerevisiae rad24
instead the correct saccharomyces
plumortholog is rad17
which is not to be confused with the
similarly named rad17 gene in
saccharomyces cerevisiae
meanwhile the human checkpoint pathway
genes are sometimes named after the
saccharomyces cerevisiae orthologs
sometimes after the saccharomyces palm
orthologs and sometimes have
independently derived names a more
subtle problem is the clash of concepts
as users move from one database to
another
for example the use of the term
pseudogene genomic variant
and even the concept of the gene itself
can mean radically different things to
different research communities
some researchers treat the gene as the
transcriptional unit itself
whereas others extend this definition to
include up and downstream regulatory
elements
and still others use the classical
definitions of cistern and genetic
complementation
there are also technical challenges the
various biological databases use
different dbms
and none provide a standard way of
accessing the data
even more challenging is the issue of
updates
biological databases are always changing
so integration must be an ongoing task
there are main ways an integration of
biological databases can be achieved
first link integration link integration
has been by far the most successful
because it lends itself to the haphazard
nature of the web
in the familiar and ubiquitous version
of this technique
researchers begin their query with one
data source
and then follow hypertext links to
related information in other data
sources
second a variation on link integration
is embodied in the popular sequence
retrieval system
which is a keyword indexing and search
system for biological databases
sequence retrieval system is more
sophisticated than general web-based
search tools
for example google because it recognizes
the existence of structured fields in
source databases
and allows maintainers to explicitly
relate a field in one database to a
differently named field in another
unfortunately link integration is
problematic on several fronts
first it is extraordinarily vulnerable
to naming clashes and ambiguities
for example a naive researcher who tries
to navigate through the rad24 gene
confusion using srs
or direct database to database linking
might wander into the wrong gene family
second there are update issues an
outgoing web link represents a leap of
faith that the page at the other end of
the link is still valid or if it exists
at all
for example if the curators of the
saccharomyces cerevisiae database
withdraw or rename rad24
they have no way of informing all the
databases that point to the rad24 page
that an update is required
third view integration view integration
leaves the information in its source
databases
but builds an environment around the
databases that makes them all seem to be
part of one large system
despite the appeal of this approach the
system has failed to catch on with the
community
fourth data warehousing data warehousing
can be broadly described as bringing all
the data under one roof in a single
database
the first step in data warehousing is to
develop a unified data model that can
accommodate all the information that is
contained in the various source
databases
the next step is to develop a series of
software programs that will fetch the
data from the source databases
transform them to match the unified data
model and then load them into the
warehouse
the warehouse can then be used as a
one-stop shop for answering any of the
questions that the source databases can
handle
as well as those that require integrated
knowledge that the individual sources do
not have
however it is more difficult to create a
data warehouse than
it might sound the single biggest issue
is keeping the data warehouse up to date
new information is being continually
added to the source databases
which means that the new data must be
re-imported into the warehouse in a
timely fashion or the warehouse will go
out of date
to make matters worse database designs
do not stand still
their maintainers are continually
tinkering with the data model by adding
new data types
changing fields and nomenclature and
changing the relationships among data
types
this constant churn means that dump
transform and load software that have
been written for one version of a
database will not necessarily work with
a later version
fifth web services an important variant
of link level integration
is the concept of the web service in
this view
the heterogeneous collection of loosely
linked data resources on the web is
turned on its head
and becomes a world of services that are
linked by service names and definitions
in such a world genbank is no longer a
database from which users retrieve
sequence entries
instead it is a service that transforms
sequence accession numbers
into genbank flat files this concept
might seem a minor point
but it allows users to establish a
common framework that encompasses
for example the blast search engine
which transforms a search sequence into
a series of similarity hit records on a
selected query database
finally establishment of globally unique
identifiers
recall the issues that the same
biological object might have multiple
names
and the same name might denote multiple
objects
one approach is to designate an
authoritative names commission to manage
the definitive list of such names
sue effort is currently being handled by
the hugo gene nomenclature committee
or hgnc in short
you